welcome to this video I'm playing I am
and step by step yeah this is one of
those guys who I have zero squad but do
I have eight and a half out of 21 it's
really bad ok so I'm going to play my
book report wha once again I haven't I
don't know don't really fare well
against him with that he's playing the
best line for white here so not easy but
anyway let's let's get going and see
what happens this time I'm a quickie at
the start
interesting with the early early before
okay yeah is preventing 95 but that's
not a move that I will play that often
anyway interesting so probably here and
what is he going to go where for he's
playing that very well this kind of
position I don't know what it is kind of
kind of tricky so
yeah how to play that not sure if my
queen is set great on e 7 I was
threatening be takes a five so I'm
getting out of this B takes a five idea
we can take and play Queen to be six
this is possible
okay miss gotten the beef file but he's
given me some control here over c5
interesting i came i can get this to see
five as well now it's right in 2nite a 4
that's not bad this position for me
night FYI is allowing editor I can go
with g6 that's also not bad getting the
bishop pair back okay well I'm find him
and definitely have a fine position it's
porn structures not that not that great
night a4 so an ATM
ok so don't you get the king of 94 I
mean I could have played that but it
wouldn't have helped that much
interesting i can go at five now gaining
space let's do that not totally sure but
some space should be helpful ki only six
i cannot play look bh so easily because
he will take a five at the end that's a
slight problem but ok let's gain the
space here and see what is doing
Shampoo crook to g8 or something it's
not helping a lot the night to d4 would
be cool if I get that in but don't see
it don't see that happening at the moon
cannot go to the B file at a promise
it's really a bit of a nuisance yeah I'm
not sure to do
yeah you can take the apron now but it's
not it's not that that problematic okay
I thought you for now would be good
attacking us MLF three if you take that
I have every check which activates a lot
I mean probably will win upon I don't
that's interesting I can play you three
or i can just take it just take it try
to invade with a new g2
okay let's keep this for the moment
h2 is an idea so I can invade now not
sure how much it Nets me okay this is
threatening not much I can take 494 I
steady move 94 and then oh it's pretty
dangerous I can't threaten that with
this
ok
look at 4i can take f2 493 check that is
good for black or winning I think so we
cannot take on f4 and I have night is
six just keeping that porn I wonder if
that is a good idea I it's not necessary
time at least I can do that look at four
that's 93 that should really win win the
house okay yeah yeah I'm taking home a
check Andrew gauge one checkmate white
resins that was good I think on a decent
game yeah I always struggle against this
guy and he again had a decent position
out of the opening but yeah this is this
is one of the best lines that white can
play against this line with e3 and this
kind of structure is a little bit better
for white that sir even I mean that's
what I'm saying also in my book i'm not
claiming that black is great here so
let's see what happens that this kind of
structure is slightly better for Wyatt
but not the end of the world but at some
point he starts to play it play it badly
yeah I'm not sure about this capture and
entering on b6 giving me the c5 squares
is really helpful
so something like this that's a little
bit better for black but it gets it gets
worse yeah this this thing I don't know
starting with really much better yeah
Luke GA is also given by the engine but
now it wants to take on g3 play it in a
simple way ok I didn't really think it
is that great like this I you cannot
even play a fire that's silly that's
silly yeah widest really and in bad
shape then if you cannot cover three
it's also not helping now ok that would
have been better even but it maintains a
clear advantage what I did check h5 now
you cannot play perfectly in those games
but I'm glad if I'm maintaining a big
advantage I'm fine I a 94 was much
stronger in the air ok antiques and just
wins the rook but I don't I don't really
think he has a defense IAM Luke takes
his six would have been much more
tenacious
I was seeing that this is not working
check check this is this a song um but
it is the case that this is even
stronger after that i'm meeting him
really it's just too much and TI could
have taken already yeah that's a nice
move I only saw the mating idea one move
later after that check um computer gives
this as minus minus 3 yeah okay this is
a move I would have found so after that
this has to take and now is have
exchanged down and then totally in in
this rain so I think it was a decent
game okay well thanks for watching